In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 30th, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostles,
Silas, Sylvan, Crescens, Epinetos, and Andronicos of the Seventy.
On the 30th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostles, Silas, Sylvanas,
Epinetos, Crescens, and Andronicos.
These Holy Apostles were part of the College of the Seventy.
A leading figure in the Church of Jerusalem, known for his prophetic gifts, Saint Silas was
sent with Saint Paul and Barnabas to confirm the faith of the Christians in Antioch.
When Paul undertook his Second Missionary Journey, he took Silas as his companion.
They journeyed together through Syria, Celicia, Lyconia, Frigia, Galatia, and Messia, before
arriving in Troas.
Going from there to Macedonia, Silas was brought before the Tribunal and imprisoned with Paul.
But when the authorities realized that they were Roman citizens, they were freed with
apologies.
They then traveled to preach the good news in Thessalonica and in Berea, where Silas stayed
with Saint Timothy and labored to confirm the faith of the new converts, while Paul continued
his journey in the direction of Athens.
All three met up at Corinth, where they preached Christ Jesus, the Son of God.
Ecclesiastical tradition recounts that he became Bishop of Corinth, where he worked to have
the recommendations contained in Paul's letters implemented, to set the Corinthians
a right and to establish them securely in charity.
After toiling ceaselessly to this end and enduring many hardships, he fell asleep in peace and
departed to the Lord.
It is said that Saint Silvanos became Bishop of Thessalonica.
He encountered continual dangers and difficulties in his work of preserving the faith for the
inhabitants of Thessalonica were adept in the art of sophistry and the double understanding
of language.
After having fought the good fight, he fell asleep in peace.
The Holy Apostle, Epenetos, is mentioned by Saint Paul as the first fruit of Asia, referring
here to the region of Ephesus.
Ecclesiastical tradition says that he later became Bishop of Carthage, and that he underwent
many trials and tribulations from the pagans who lived in that region.
His patience and words of fire succeeded in bringing a great number to the knowledge of
the truth, and he gave his soul into God's hands after worthily fulfilling his mission.
Saint Cressons was also a disciple of Saint Paul, and is mentioned by the latter as having
been sent to Galatia.
He became Bishop of Calcedon and rescued a great number of pagans who were living in darkness
by showing them the light of the truth.
After having condemned sin in his own flesh and having delivered many souls from perdition,
teaching them the faith and an evangelical manner of life, he fell asleep in the Lord.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on
us and save us.